الى انقره من هناك مراسلات الجزيره فرح
الزمان
شوقي اخر المستجدات اخر الاحصائيات
والارقام والمتابعات فرح
عبد القادر بالنسبه للقتله ما زلنا عند
ذات الارقام التي اعلنت عنها افاد اكثر من
31 الف قتيل وعدد الجرحى لم يتم تحديثه
منذ يوم امس وصحيح اننا كنا امام بعض
حالات الانقاذ لكن يعني للاسف لا يمكن
وصفها الا بانها بضع عشرات من الحالات منذ
يوم امس وطالما ان افاد والرئاسه التركيه
تتحدث عن ان العمليات ستبقى مستمره حتى
اخراج كل العالقين من تحت الانقاد فاننا
سنكون امام زياده في الارقام وامام
تحديثات اخرى في الساعات القادمه
تحديث اخر يتعلق بعدد الهزات الارتداديه
ازدادت الهزات الارتداديه لتتجاوز 2,700
هزه نتحدث عن 300 هزه خلال يوم واحد اخر
هذه الهزات 4.7
شدتها 4.7 كانت في غازي عنتاب الجميع هناك
شعر بها حتى ان
انا في فريق الجزيره اكدوا بانها كانت هزه
شديده هنالك ارقام ايضا صدرت من وزاره
البيئه تتحدث عن معاينه مليون و 200 الف
وحده سكنيه في اكثر من 236 الف بناء هذه
المعاينه تخرج بنتيجه
153 الف وحده سكنيه اصبحت غير صالحه للسكن
وتحتاج الى هدم عاجل او انها مهدمه صحيح
ان هذا الرقم
بالنسبه الى مليون و200 الف يعتبر ليس
كبيرا كثيرا لكن هذه المعاينه تتحدث عن
بقعه صغيره هذه العمليات عمليه المعاينات
والتقييمات بدات فقط منذ يومين وسنكون
امام مساحه جغرافيه واسعه وسنكون امام
المزيد من الارقام والمزيد من الاضرار
وهذه التقييمات تجريها فرق خاصه
بيئه افاد مسؤوله عن تقييم هذه المباني
وستصدر تقاريرها للمد
وتتحدثون عن كارثه انسانيه يجب ان يقف
فيها الجميع مع تركيا على حد وصفها
بالنسبه لوزير الخارجيه التركي الذي اثنى
ايضا على هذا الموقف الليبي يتحدث عن ان
اكثر من 9000 شخص اجنبي يتواجدون في
الميدان الان لمساعده تركيا ويتحدث عن
تلقي عروض بمبادره جديده ارسال المزيد من
الخيام وما الى ذلك لكن نقطه هامه في
تصريحات وزير الخارجيه التركي المتعلقه
بسوريا او المساعدات الى سوريا يؤكد مجددا
بان المعابر التركيه مع سوريا شهدت اضرارا
لوجستيا جسيمه يتحدث هنا عن ان مرور
المساعدات الى سوريا عبر هذه المعابر لا
يعني بالضروره لجوء المزيد من السوريين
نحو تركيا لان هنالك ما يشبه الحمله
التحريضيه والاستفزازيه داخل تركيا وينتقد
الوزير هذا الامر ويقول بان هذه المساعدات
تمر عبر الامم المتحده من معبرين ايضا دور
بعض وتصريحات بعض الدول الغربيه ليؤكد بان
اي من هذه الدول اذا ما ارادت ان تنقل
اللاجئين السوريين من على الاراضي التركيه
فالاجواء مفتوحه ويؤكد بان تركيا بالنسبه
لها تفتح معابرها وترسل المساعدات المخصصه
لسوريا عبر معبرين تشرف عليهما الامم
المتحده الان عبد القادر فرح بالعوده الى
المركز حيث انت مركز افاد هل هناك خليه
لتلقي الشكاوى ومتابعتها وبالتالي تدارك
الاخطاء ان وجدت
نعم نعم بالفعل في غرفه العمليات هنالك
عده ارقام مخصصه للمواطنين الاتراك واحده
من هذه الارقام
مخصصه لمساله تلقي الشكاوي على الارض
هنالك ارقام مخصصه للاشخاص المتواجدين في
المناطق المنكوبه والمتضرره وارقام اخرى
في المدن الثانيه ممن يريدون التحرك نحو
المناطق المتضرره يوجد في افاد غرفه
لتنسيق العمليات هذا المكان يعتبر هو
المركز منه تنطلق الفرق والمساعدات الى
المناطق المنكوبه ومنه تتحرك الفرق الاخرى
القادمه من هناك الى المدن الثانيه نتحدث
هنا عن الاجلاء وبخصوص الشكاوى كنت قد
طرحت هذا السؤال في وقت سابق حين زرنا
غرفه العمليات نعم من المفترض ان يكون
هناك اشخاص يتلقون هذه الشكاوى الموجوده
على الارض لكن في الحقيقه عبد القادر نحن
نتحدث عن مساحه جغرافيه هائله عن اضرار
كبيره ومن الطبيعي الاستماع لبعض المشكلات
والتبعات على الارض هنالك تبعات غير
التبعات التي نراها من قبيل المنازل
المتضرره حصيله كبيره من القتلى والجرحى
تبعات كثيره من قبيل التبعات الامنيه
الاقتصاديه الاجتماعيه يقول المسؤولون في
تركيا بانهم يحاولون تدارك هذه التبعات
وزاره الداخليه مثلا اجرت يوم امس اجتماعا
وصفته بالاجتماع التنسيقي مع ممثلينا من
وزارات ثانيه وذلك لتنسيق هذه العمليات
عبد القادر
شوقي من انقره شكرا جزيلا لك